Now, we're going to switch gears and move to a different catagory of mental
disorders. And those are disssociative disorders. These disorders produce
extreme disruptions or gaps in memory, identity, or consciousness. In the DSM 5
puts them in their own category. This is a condition in which cognitive
processes are disjointed and fragmented. This disorder often stems from
exposure to trauma or extreme stress. And even physical or sexual assault that
occurs. And it's most likely to occur during childhood. Individuals with
dissociative identity disorder will develop at least two separate, independent
identities. Now this used to be called multiple personality disorder. These
individuals experience two or more distinct personality states amnesia and self
destructive behaviors. Here, a person may find themselves at a hotel and not
remember how they got there. They may injure themselves or not be able to
remember a particular experience in their life. This is reportedly due to the
fact that the other personality is the one engaging in these behaviors. This
disorder is another example of a position that psychologists disagree on. Some
psychologists don't agree that this is an actual diagnosis. Some even suggest
that the separate personalities are ultimately produced by the therapist. So we
see here that some psychologist state that this is a real disorder, and some
state that it's not. Now let's go back to Susan, to talk about disorders that
affect the body, and the mind.